you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
calls for the government to do more to
reduce the cost of energy but will it be
at the expense of climate targets
germany's new climate minister pushes
renewable power and immigration to
tackle the gigantic task of reaching net
zero by 2050
hs2 trains set to be powered using zero
carbon electricity
and how melting permafrost could be
damaging critical infrastructure in the
arctic
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now tackling the rising cost of energy
is on everyone's mind this year during
these cold winter months and with a
warning that gas and electricity prices
are set to rise by as much as 50 percent
well today labor turned up the heat on
the government saying that a lack of
proper investment in green solutions
means it's failed to act to protect
consumers against global price hikes
while proposing a cut to vat on
household bills shadow chancellor rachel
reeves said that its poorest households
that will be impacted the most the
beneficiaries of this will be those
people the people who we know need that
support more than anyone
we have had a decade of diver and delay
from the conservatives on energy policy
now there is indeed a global price spike
for gas but this government has left
britain uniquely exposed
they have failed to properly insulate
homes or to invest in the new nuclear or
renewables that we need they have failed
on gas storage leaving us reliant on
russia and qatar for our gas supply they
have failed to regulate the market with
27 companies now gone bankrupt and that
has left rising prices hitting millions
well let's bring in our business
correspondent paul kelso
so paul the government's been accused of
not protecting consumers against high
energy prices so what are their options
and could any decision they make
actually have an impact on the country's
net zero targets
it may well do uh but that very much
depends on which a rather limited
list of options the chance from the
prime minister choose to proceed with to
deal with what is a very very difficult
issue politically and uh beyond that the
reason it's politically difficult it's a
very real issue for so many households
the upcoming price hike in energy bills
is going to be such that all but the
most affluent are going to notice it
those least able to afford a rise are
going to feel it very heavily indeed the
vat cut label was pressing for today
would save around say around 60 pounds
on your current bill and around 90
pounds on the anticipated bills the
prime minister's already pretty much
ruled that out there's a lot of heat
though around the issue of policy costs
so called which include green levees
these are the taxis it's wakes up around
12
of bills it's technically loaded onto
electricity bills at the moment now the
energy industry would like to see all
those levees shifted into general
taxation they say it will be more
progressive that is the richest would
bear more of the burden because the
richest pay more into general taxation
but at the moment it's shared across
everybody's bills and it includes things
like schemes that require energy
providers to pay for new boilers
improved insulation in the homes of
those uh the poorest families those in
fuel poverty and a host of other uh
green seen as decarbonization measures
like uh paying those who have solar
panels on their roofs to feed energy
back into the grid again there's some
resistance today uh in the debate in the
commons as to uh moving those the
the the aim isn't necessarily to cut
those those levies entirely but to shift
them into general taxation but that
takes time that would also require the
chancellor to carve out a lot of money
from taxation to spend on those green
issues so it really does depend which
way the government jumps in reality
they're probably going to have to do a
lot of these things at once to have any
kind of major impact on what could be a
rise to the average bill of around 700
pounds a year so the chance of somehow
is going to have to subsidize some of
the government prefer to subsidize
consumers those least able to pay than
the energy providers but there really
aren't many good options
well let's take a look then at our data
dashboard which shows where the energy
is coming from in great britain at the
moment and fossil fuels make up more
than 50 percent of the power mix that
includes gas as paul was saying 53.6
percent from gas a 2.2 percent there
from coal and also you can see the
renewables figure as well just over 20
are coming from renewables in that power
mix right now so that's what's happening
in great britain but what about other
parts of the world well in germany the
new climate minister said that the
country faces a gigantic task if it
wants to achieve its goals for reducing
greenhouse gas emissions renewable
sources such as solar and wind power
currently provide about 43 of germany's
electricity but robert harbeck said that
share needs to almost double to 80
percent to achieve net zero by 2050. so
let's take you live now to our europe
correspondent adam parsons so adam how
does the government there intend to go
about it then
well the first thing to say is that this
government is a coalition robert harbeck
is a green politician he's the climate
minister uh and it is him saying that
germany has got to get a move on faces
this gigantic challenge
of meeting its emissions targets now his
ideas uh include some of the things that
paul kelso was just talking about there
shunting the the levees from consumers
onto central federal government backing
putting incentives in place for
businesses to use solar panel and also
throwing an awful lot of money
at wind power he's now got to get this
through though legislation
he's got two big tranches that he wants
to put in place and he says this is
urgent he says germany actually
increased its emissions last year that
it will miss its climate targets and 22
and 23. and germany has a pretty steep
target
of reducing emissions by to 65 by 65
from their 1990 uh target by 2030 that
is an even steeper target than the
european union has set for itself now
what he did also say is that germany is
still going to have to lean on gas and
that is enormously controversial across
europe because this this new list of of
supported gas systems the germans say
they need to have gas the french say
they want to have nuclear germans
extremely angry about that because of
course they are phasing out nuclear
power so that is leading to around the
extension that there's been extension
now to the deadline for when an
agreement has to be found around these
uh this approval for this new power
system uh the greens are digging their
feet and this clearly is how they want
to make their mark
on german policies but another
interesting thing that robert hubback
said
is that the workforce that will be open
to germany is going to decline because
germany like so many countries uh is
faced with an ageing population he says
that that will reduce the number of
people that is open and what does he say
that means says that means that germany
needs to expand the number of migrants
that it attracts in order to boost this
new economy this new greener economy
that he envisages
adam thank you
hs2 trains will be powered using zero
carbon electricity the government
announced the plans as part of its
pledge to reduce all greenhouse gas
emissions to net zero by 2050. the first
phase of hs2 from london to birmingham
is scheduled to open sometime between
2029 and 2033.
mark thurston the chief executive of hs2
said the government and the rail
industry has the time to achieve that
goal
if we don't find a way of driving carbon
out of the built environment on a
project of our size and longevity
frankly then that will be a missed
opportunity for the whole sector so very
much we do a lot of work with the
designers and the contractors to make
sure we find every opportunity to reduce
carbon out of the railway we'll draw
power from the wider national grid of
course as part of the wider government's
commitment to more renewable sources by
then our expectation is that we'll be
using
zero carbon energy supplies i mean
already uh in certain instances now in
certain quarters in our demand for power
in the uk we take more power from
renewable sources than from carbon
sources and of course this rail opens in
the 2030 so we've got time to work with
the government and the power industry to
ensure this railway uh is is powered by
zero carbon uh green energy
some of these other climate news now and
one of britain's largest energy
companies has apologized after it
suggested that customers could cuddle
their pets and do star jumps instead of
turning on the heating ovo energy said
it was embarrassed by the blog post
which offered customers 10 tips on how
to save energy and stay warm this winter
several mps have called the comments
insulting and offensive
the mayor of london is calling on people
to reduce their car use and find greener
ways of traveling around the capital
sadiq khan says london is facing a
crisis of filthy air and gridlocked
roads as latest data reveals that car
uses nearly recovered to pre-pandemic
levels public transport is significantly
lower with buses at 70 and tube travel
at just 55
experts surveyed by the world economic
forum are more worried about climate
change than they are about coronavirus
the wef's annual risks report has found
their three biggest concerns are
insufficient climate action extreme
weather and loss of biodiversity until
now infectious diseases had been top of
the list
and i'll be asking economist vicki price
and the nature conservancy's
international climate policy director
john verdieck whether they agree with
the experts in tonight's discussion and
that's in just a few minutes time
now if you look at the earth from space
large areas are covered in ice now
that's permafrost large land masses that
are completely frozen
but the permafrost is melting and
according to a new report that's
damaging up to half of the arctic's
infrastructure here's why
[Music]
a lot of it is relatively bad conditions
right you can think about kind of
wetlands up north and a lot of that
carbon is released as nothing much more
important greenhouse gas than co2
there are direct impacts that are
already seen by people
industries by indigenous communities
that live on burma for us today
[Music]
do stay tuned coming up here on the
daily climate show i'll be joined by
economist vicki price and john verdick
the director of international climate
policy at the nature conservancy
in the u.s and we're going to be
discussing if climate change is high
enough on the uk's list of priorities
and as ketchup sachets could be
prohibited in the near future we ask
what else could britain benefit from
banning
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
economist vicky price and john verdieck
the director of international climate
policy at the nature conservancy in the
u.s so a very good evening to both of
you nice to see you both
so first of all climate change is the
biggest risk now facing humanity the
main finding from a survey of global
experts by the world economic forum in a
world still struggling with the
coronavirus pandemic that's quite a
statement so vicky what do you make of
it respondents putting
the climate change issue
front and center stage is that
surprising given the unprecedented
number of deaths and economic crises
we've seen as a result of the pandemic
which we're still dealing with
it's not totally surprising i have to
say because of course you know they've
been asked to um see and think what the
situation might be over the next few
years and what they have of course
experienced is that the threat of the
pandemic has been reduced
and remember the quality of people
who've been answering this questions
have been from europe so uh we've seen
of course uh the the omnicurrent variant
affect us but overall the impact of
these new waves is is less so they can
see growth happening they've seen growth
in fact overall during 2021 and it's
likely to be growth against economy 2022
so they can now shift the attention to
other issues and of course we had cop 26
it would be
very odd if they hadn't put the
environmental issues quite high up but
when you look at the report though and
you
look at the details of some of the
concerns that they have
there is no doubt they're still worried
about the way in which growth is
happening the fact that there is a lot
of inequality around the technological
changes taking place and particularly
they're concerned about the way in which
dealing with climate change and
environmental issues if it's done
wrongly might actually lead to even more
societal
uh discord and issues coming up when
people will find themselves either
excluded or having to pay a very big
price
uh for this transition and therefore
might nave anything resent uh what the
politicians perhaps would be trying to
do or even businesses may be trying to
do yeah john what do you make of it are
you surprised that climate is so clearly
at the top of the list of concerns
rather than the pandemic and
did these surveys make any difference do
they pay attention to them in the u.s
for example could it have an impact on
policy
yeah i totally agree with vicky um i
don't think it's surprising i think it's
it's telling though i think the success
of cop 26 coming out and just showing
how much more of the world is paying
attention to this is starting to come
out in these communiques from the from
the west um from all these different
groups and
you know i think we're going to keep
seeing it more and more
especially with the fact that climate
change we're seeing storms becoming more
severe becoming more frequent when we
start to look forward into the future
and as vikki was talking about some of
the gdp numbers and economic forecasts
going forward we're going to see that
start to make greater and greater
impacts across the board and around the
world
and and john on the point of whether or
not it could change policy these kind of
surveys that they influence politicians
absolutely you know i i think on the
other hand anything that happens locally
tends to influence politicians more than
anything that happens globally which is
why we do see a bit of this tragedy of
the commons with climate change as the
united states you know whether it's
going to be a congress person or the
president starts to see more of more of
this happen we're going to see more
action now we have seen in the united
states there's a there's a build back
better built that's been um in congress
for for quite a while and we're
disappointed to see that it hasn't gone
through yet but we're also enlightened
to see the fact that it's still on the
table and and we're hopeful
and vicky what about the uk because uk
um experts were much more worried about
the failure of cyber security than
climate change and what does that tell
us about the uk's approach do you think
i don't think it means that businesses
are not interested or the experts are
not really interested or worried about
the climate change issues it means that
there are some pressing
uh problems that need to be dealt with
and i think the
the worries that they're not addressed
uh certainly not by politicians or by
regulation and the reason for it i think
if you look at the list of countries
that have been most affected by cyber
attacks i mean yes we hear quite a lot
of sort of political cyber attacks that
take place in in various parts of the
world but in reality in terms of
businesses and the way in which they've
been affected it seems to be mostly in
the us and number two in the uk so again
it's something that businesses will be
facing increasingly and if you uh
perhaps focus too much on let's say just
climate change or maybe another issue
which is of course you know could be
quite important right now you could miss
the fact that being able to operate
in the world economy the way that one of
the businesses need to do also means
that this should be free from those
cyber attacks so at least they should be
able to
find somewhere protecting themselves
against and i think that's what's coming
up i think in the survey okay let's talk
about our next topic now shall we
because the environment secretary george
eustis could add ketchup sachets and
mini milk cartons to a plastics ban list
according to a story that featured in
the sun newspaper today now the list has
already seen the demise of plastic
straws and stirrers but are ketchup
sachets really the obvious contender for
a ban or is it simply a petty little
project as described by one think tank
vicky what do you think should we ban a
tomato ketchup sachets or should the
government be focusing on bigger issues
when it comes to the environment
i think
we could focus on bigger issues but you
can also do little things that might
make a difference in my view you know
going down this route isn't going to
really suddenly you know change the
climate change projections that that
we've got but of course every little bit
helps but if we do this here in the uk
or another little thing that makes
people feel happier perhaps that
something is being done at a micro level
the real question is is this a global
attempt i mean is this part of the
general effort against plastics for
example that we've seen uh happen you
know across the world if if it is and it
fits with it then okay that's fine as
long as we give enough warning and the
producers can have something else
instead that they can supply us with in
order that we can enjoy our whatever it
is our mcdonald's without you know our
kids screaming too much
john do you agree with that do you think
that um government should ban things
like this or should it be up to
consumers to be grown up and make the
decisions for themselves i mean how
would a ban like this go down in the
states for example do you think
yeah you know in the states it would be
mostly at a more local or a state level
that this kind of implementation could
happen and we've seen it with grocery
bags and things like that of other
single-use plastics and you know we're
supportive of taking action with
single-use plastics and reducing it it
spurs innovation to find other things
that we could do it also makes those of
us that are individual consumers start
to think about our own behavior and as
all of us start to spread our push our
own behavior in better directions we're
going to see a better a better outcome
and you know it's it's also one of the
things
as we look at ketchup we start to also
think about burgers and the things that
we use with them and how do we make
burgers more sustainable is probably the
next push on this and and how do we try
to make global emissions go down perhaps
in the amazon rainforest by making more
sustainable supply chains of the burger
to pair up with that ketchup movement
well yes so vicky does it matter which
products are particularly targeted i've
seen some commentators calling this
petty regulation other
others are even suggesting there's some
snobbery to the types of products that
are being targeted these are
sachets often seen in fast food outlets
for example does it matter which
products are targeted
well yes i think it needs to be seen
that it's not necessarily sort of
discriminating against particular parts
of the economy and i think this is a
question that needs to be addressed in
all sorts of areas for example you know
if i can digress a second and talk about
electric vehicles for example yes and
we're pushing those quite hard but in
reality quite a lot of people cannot
afford them they don't have the charging
points so and there is a feeling that
perhaps what we're doing is we're making
it much harder for those of the lower
end of the paid bracket and making it
easier for those higher up john a quick
word on what you'd like to see banned
yeah i think more rather than ban i
think we need more information uh
consumers tend to make really good
choices and just to go back to where i
just mentioned thinking about um if
we're getting beef we want to make sure
that if it's coming from the amazon that
we have reliable data that says that
this is not from an area that was
previously pristine rainforest it was
something that was used on marginalized
land that's already in existence and the
consumers can then make the choice and
make sure that's what's on their dinner
table or what their what they're buying
from a restaurant is actually good for
the planet okay well john verdick and
vicki price really interesting to talk
to you tonight thanks very much indeed
for your time
thank you
well tomorrow i'll be joined by xihu
honorary fellow at oxford's
environmental change institute and
richard black senior associate at the
energy and climate intelligence unit
thanks for watching i'll see you next
time
[Music]